[Musique]
c'est l'heure de l'invité politique
aujourd'hui je reçois eric ciotti député
les républicains des alpes-maritimes
bonjour eric ciotti chaud alors nous
sommes ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse régionale et pour la représenter
aujourd'hui à qui mieux que denis carot
le patron des rédactions du groupe nice
matin bonjour denis bonjour alors eric
ciotti on va commencer par parler à de
la commission d'enquêté de l'assemblée
nationale sur la gestion de la crise
sanitaire du coroner du courant un virus
vous êtes le rapporteur de cette
commission denquête et aujourd'hui vous
auditionné le professeur didier raoult
est un grand personnage de cette crise
sanitaire didier rahout qui a dit hier
dans les colonnes de la provence
qu'on aurait pu faire deux fois deux
fois moins de morts en france dans cette
crise du cornât virus car on n'a pas
assez soignée est ce qu'on s'est trompé
de stratégie sanitaire
ça sera l'objet de cette commission
denquête la réponse à cette question
fera partie des conclusions que la
commission d'enquêté le rapporteur que
je suis seront amenés à émettre dans
quelques mois
ce sont ces questions que nous posons
quelle a été la pertinence de la
stratégie sanitaire calais quels ont été
les moyens ont ils été suffisant pour y
faire face
on a déjà bien avancé d'abord je veux
dire cette commission travaille bien et
ça c'est déjà un point positif il y
avait des inquiétudes au début entre la
présidente brigitte bourguignon et les
membres de la commission
on a conduit la semaine dernière
notamment un travail de très grande
qualité qui nous a permis déjà de
beaucoup avancé on a avancé sur la
question des masques où on a pu mesurer
que nous avions à peine un peu plus de
100 millions de masses emparé au début
de la crise que les commandes
essentielles n'ont été pas c'est qu'au
mois de mars
donc il y a eu ce délai très long ce
manque d'anticipation et surtout que
nous avions que les autorités sanitaires
que la ministre de la santé que le
directeur général de la santé avait en
leurs mains des notes de scientifiques
qui disait il faut un milliard de
masques qu'ils avaient également une
autre disant que la plupart des masques
étaient périmés or quasiment aucune
commande
puis dans la période où il ya eu ces
notes c'est à dire septembre 2018
jusqu'à la crise n'ont été faites donc
on a avancé je prends ce sujet concret
aujourd'hui on aura une figure de cette
crise le professeur didier raoul qui a
été au coeur de controverses d'ailleurs
on posera la question sur l'utilité de
ces controverses dans une période de
crise est-ce que fallait pas qu'ils unis
ty de la communauté scientifique
pourquoi il ya eu ces blocages je lui
poserai personnellement la question
parce que on peut il ya le débat sur les
drogues si chloroquine bien sûr qui a
animé les les commentaires et les
tensions mais il y a aussi et surtout je
dirais peut-être la stratégie de test du
professeur out qui là est
incontestablement une très grande
réussite pourquoi lui a réussi
et pourquoi en france on a ce constat
dressé par le président du conseil
scientifique au début de la crise à
peine 3000 test par jour en france 50
milles en allemagne et toutes nos
auditions de vie c'est justement sur le
n'a manqué de ces éléments et qui nous
ont conduits en confinement sans doute
plus drastiques
eric ciotti justement sur les tests et
bien le professeur raoul tu dis qu'il
fallait vraiment à tester tout le monde
même les passions sans symptôme des
passions 156 heures il y avait des
lésions graves aux poumons
mais la stratégie du conseil
scientifique ce n'était que de tester
les patients avec symptômes il ya
vraiment une erreur là sur ce point
c'était pas la stratégie du conseil
s'est en effet créé était que c'était la
stratégie du ministre de la santé parce
qu'il n'y avait pas les moyens de faire
ces tests est parce qu il y a eu des
blocages administratifs bureaucratiques
qui ont empêché par exemple que les
laboratoires vétérinaires en attendant
les partants des alpes-maritimes puisse
être associé à la crise que les
laboratoires privés
il s'a mis un temps fou pour que les
laboratoires privés soient mis dans la
boucle à nice dans ma ville
les tests été fait à marseille pendant
presque trois semaines on n'avait pas pu
mettre en place les les tests donc il ya
eu ces retards depuis la manquer à peu
près tout de réactifs découvrions pour
faire les prélèvements
donc il faut qu'on sache pourquoi il y a
eu quelque part ce déficit de moyens
mais
ce qui est clair c'est que l'institut
universitaire hospitalo universitaires
chu du professeur août à une
extraordinaire réussite sur les tests et
douala dans cette fameuse controverse
sur la chloroquine avec le professeur
aura hoult beaucoup de personnalités à
droite ont soutenu l'utilisation de la
chloroquine est ce que le professeur
raoul ce n'est pas devenu et bien un
idole politique de la droite
je crois que la question se pose pas en
ces termes c'est une question
scientifique
moi j'étais un peu sur les responsables
politiques devaient s'engager j'ai été
surpris par la violence des réactions de
partait de part et d'autre c'est un
débat qui doit être scientifique serein
nous lui poserons cette question moi je
suis pas médecin je suis pas je suis pas
scientifique
il faut dans une période de crise une
mobilisation générale et tout le monde
doit
voilà le professeur à outils a participé
les attaques la violence aussi des
attaques contre lui
quelque part mme ma choquer alors
parlons du risque de deuxième vague
l'allemagne confine l'ouest du pays ça
concerne cinq cent mille personnes
et justement ce risque de deuxième vague
il ressort dans les premières auditions
de la commission d'enquêté le conseil
scientifique le professeur delfraissy
les les épidémiologistes que nous avons
entendues pour beaucoup avec des
réserves mais évoque la probabilité d'un
rebond d'une deuxième vague
certaines disent c'est pas la deuxième
vague mais ce seront des des clusters
hier l'ancien directeur général de la
santé william dab nous a dit ça donc il
faut être prêt et c'est l'objectif de
cette commission denquête c'est pas de
faire un procès politique c'est pas de
faire un procès judiciaire
il y à des instances pour les français
jugeront comment le gouvernement a géré
cette crise j'ai mon avis vous le
connaissez les s'il ya des
responsabilités pénales notamment dans
la prise en compte de nos aînés dans
l'est dans les ehpad parce que c'est un
sujet majeur que l'on va aborder 10000
morts dans les ehpad
est-ce qu'ils ont été pris en charge
suffisamment dans les hôpitaux est ce
qu'ils ont été soignés mais nous ce que
nous voulons c'est dire si de même par
malheur ça se reproduit est-ce que nous
serons prêts
nous n'avons pas été prêt en janvier
nous n'avons pas et des prêts en février
nous n'avons pas été pris en mars
il faut qu'on soit prêt en septembre ou
en octobre voilà eric ciotti est ce que
on va trop vite dans le déconfinement on
a vu par exemple des images de foules
dimanche lors de la fête de la musique
quand on voit effectivement la situation
en allemagne avec ses six mille six cent
mille personnes qui vont être
reconfirmer est ce qu'on ne peut pas se
poser la question
bien sûr cette question se pose mais
avant ces images de la fête de la
musique je peux comprendre qu'il ait
envie des français qui ont été confinés
d'avoir aussi des moments de détente
mais il ya eu ces images rappelez vous
ces manifestations 25000 personnes à
paris devant le tribunal judiciaire pour
une manifestation interdite quand on
tolère ça après il ya plus de limites on
peut pas soit on a une rigueur pour tout
le monde qui s'imposent mais on peut pas
dire à la manifestation c'est pas grave
tout le monde est confiné tout le monde
des séries et puis après le reste on
peut pas être à plus 10 quand on a donné
cet exemple quand le gouvernement à
baisser la garde a dit on on laisse
faire la manifestation ce qui était une
folie sanitaire en plaine en pleine
période de risque elle était interdite
mais on l'a tolérée
à partir de là les vannes sont ouvertes
bien sûr que c'est dangereux bien sûr
que c'est risqué et bien sûr que c'est
irresponsable
eric ciotti on va à évoquer une page
judiciaire et notamment les liens entre
la justice et la politique avec deux
affaires d'abord la sphère alexis kohler
et un rebondissement à danser dans cette
affaire alors j'explique le contexte le
secrétaire général de l'elysée faisait
l'objet d'une enquête du parquet
national financiers pour avoir dissimulé
et bien à ses liens familiaux et
professionnels avec l'armateur msc
cette enquête a été classée sans suite
mais hier mediapart a révélé et bien une
note écrite par le président la
république emmanuel macron qui
dédouanent alexis colère sur ses liens
avec m et c est après cette note
personnelle et bien elle a été transmise
au parquet national financier qui a donc
ensuite classé l'enquêté sans suite
est ce que c'est une intervention du
président de la république dans une
affaire judiciaire
bien sûr c'est une intervention et
la question se pose avec bien sûr cette
intervention de la suite judiciaire qui
a été réservé parce qu'on a l'impression
que les deux aspects sont liés
l'intervention du président la
république
et puis le classement dans une période
un peu un peu particulière au parc
national financier mais au delà qu'est
ce qu'il y a comme question il y à la
question de l'indépendance de la justice
et notamment de l'indépendance du
parquet national financiers pourquoi ce
parquet national financier a été créé
personnellement je considère qu'il n'y
avait aucune justification à créer ce
parc national financiers on a dû si ce
qui est organisée il y avait le parquet
de paris ce parquet national financiers
pèsent sur lui
le soupçon d'une juridiction politique
voulue par françois hollande pour régler
ses comptes avec ses adversaires
et depuis que kylie à l'existence de ce
parc national financiers on a quand même
le sentiment que systématiquement les
opposants du pouvoir sont les cibles et
on l'a vu de façon totalement
scandaleuse avec françois fillon parle
et que de l'autre côté ceux qui sont
proches du pouvoir bénéficier d'une
beaucoup plus grande indulgence et d'une
poule plus grande clémence
donc c'est ça qui pose un problème
démocratique majeur mais cette affaire
fillon et l'a révélé révélations qu'on
fait le café
madame madame houlette son ancien
rockeur national saison sur les photos
stupéfiante sont stupéfiantes parce que
derrière qu'est ce qu'il y a derrière il
ya le cours de la france qui a été
modifié parce que si françois fillon
n'avait pas été mis en examen avec la
rapidité avec la célérité sans aucune
forme de débat contradictoire avec une
enquête préliminaire totalement à charge
avec la désignation d'un magistrat qui a
en un week end alors qu'il est nommé le
vendredi soir et qu'il ne devrait pas
être nommé parce que c'est pas moi qui
le dit ce sont les deux journalistes du
monde gérard davet et fabrice lhomme qui
peuvent pas pourtant être soupçonné de
grande amitié née fillonniste ni sarkozy
sont le psy qui disent c'est la juge
simon qui devait être désigné mais on
fait en sorte de façon procédurales avec
un petit subterfuge que ça soit le juge
tournaire elle
je tournais bas ils cherchent pas à
comprendre en 48 heures sans regarder le
dossier
par miracle il décide la mise en examen
de françois fillon on savait que
françois fillon avait dit si j'étais
bien examen je serai pas candidat donc
les conséquences politiques
elles sont gigantesques elle sort ce
procès sont énormes ce qu'il faudrait
faire le débat que ce prix est bien sûr
mais françois fillon le demande mais je
crois qu'aujourd'hui il faut redonner de
la sérénité il faut arrêter il faut
sortir la politique de la justice c'est
essentiel c'est essentiel parce que il
en va de la vitalité de notre démocratie
mais s'ils s'étaient passés ça en
hongrie ou en russie mais correct on dit
qu'aurait-on dit mais nous sommes dans
une démocratie c'est notre démocratie
qu'est fragilisé c'est un scandale
d'état il faut aller au bout de cette
affaire parce que il y a eu des
conséquences terribles pour le pays
alors justement comment interprétez vous
la décision d' emmanuel macron de saisir
le conseil supérieur de la magistrature
pour lever tout doute sur l'indépendance
et l'impartialité de la justice dans
cette affaire
c'est une bonne chose je les demande et
donc je vais pas dire le contraire je
lui ai écrit dès qu' on a eu ces
éléments la semaine dernière la
maternelle j'ai immédiatement écrit à
emmanuel macron ne m'a pas répondu à mon
rythme et j'ai vu que j'ai pas là j'ai
la prétention de dire c'est uniquement
pour ça mais j'ai fait également une
autre chose j'ai écrit à madame bello b
pour lui demander de saisir le parti
pour qu'ils aient une enquête judiciaire
il faut qu'ils aient une enquête
judiciaire ce qu'a dit sous serment
madame houlette relève de faits
extrêmement graves qui peuvent relever
de la forfaiture
donc il faut qui est une enquête
judiciaire
naturellement l'inspection des services
judiciaires mais moi je crois qu'il faut
aujourd'hui qu' un juge d'instruction
qui n de façon indépendante instruisent
et regarde ce qui s'est passé voilà
pourquoi il y a eu des pressions
pourquoi il ya vu la désignation d'un
juge qui n'aurait pas dû être désignée
pourquoi il ya eu cette mise en examen
sans caractère contradictoire parce que
il en va de de la confiance de nos
concitoyens
d'abord dans l'institution judiciaire
mais au delà
dans notre fonctionnement démocratique
parce que si on peut éliminer le
principal opposant du pouvoir à un mois
de la présidentielle
où va-t-on où va-t-on ça ne s'était
jamais vu vous avez y avait toujours eu
dans la vème république
cette idée que à quelques semaines d'une
élection quelle qu'elle soit il ya une
trêve judiciaire parce qu'il faut pas
que la justice soit instrumentalisée et
là manifestement on ça n'ait servi et
que la justice modifie le cours du
processus électoral et démocratique
alors il se tient on va évoquer les
violences policières mais avant cela une
question rapide sur la lutte antiraciste
et à la statue de colbert à l'assemblée
nationale qui hier a été taguée avec
l'inscription un négrophobie d'état vous
avez été choqué par ce tag
oui j'ai été j'ai été choqué qu'on
compte des grades un bâtiment public il
ya il ya eu deux dégradations il ya vu
l'assemblée nationale mais a eu aussi le
ministère de l'intérieur place beauvau
avec le militant s'est enchaîné voilà et
puis avec des jets de censure sur les
murs du ministère de l'intérieur
d'ailleurs c'est totalement ahurissant
en matière de maintien de l'ordre
que monsieur castaner ne soit même pas
capable on savait qu'il n'était pas
capable de protéger les français mais
qu'il est même pas capable de protéger
son ministère à 50 mètres de l'entrée du
palais de l'elysée ça démontre combien
nos outils de protection se sont
extraordinairement affaibli mais
arrêtons avec ces débats on juge avec
des valeurs qui d'ailleurs viennent
d'autres pays des états unis et nous
n'avons pas la même histoire que les
états unis les états unis on peut
comprendre l'extrême émotion la
sensibilité c'est un pays qui a été
ségrégationniste qui a été esclavagiste
la france est le pays des lumières qui
s'est extrait très vide tout ça donc on
juge avec les valeurs des états unis au
21ème siècle de ce qui s'est passé il y
à il ya cinq cents ans donc c'est pas ou
un peu plus tôt mais c'est pas crédible
on va juger les hommes du de des
cavernes avec nos valeurs aujourd'hui
non arrêtons de réécrire voilà
l'histoire c'est en bloc
l'histoire est là ces zones d'ombré de
lumière il y à des figures elles ont
fait la france a l'on fait évoluer
progrès
c'est dans un esprit démocratie arrêtons
cette culpabilisation permanente qui est
vraiment ridicule
alors au delà du débat sur le racisme on
a parlé des violences policières avec
des policiers qui ont été condamnés ou
en tout cas et bien entre mise en examen
par la justice pour leur violence face
au gilet jaune
un policier condamné à 18 mois de prison
avec sursis pour avoir matraqué une
retraitée gilet jaune et puis quatre
policiers ayant frappé des gilets jaunes
dans un restaurant en décembre 2018 ont
été mises en examen
cela montre quand même qu'il ya beaucoup
de violence policière dans notre société
aujourd'hui il peut y avoir et vous
évoquez des faits qui ont posé problème
difficulté et ils sont contrôlés et ils
sont sanctionnés vous savez l'année
dernière l'inspection générale des
services a conduit 1400 enquête et il y
a eu plus de 3 presque 300 sanctions
administratives et il ya eu 32
révocation quelle profession peut dire
qu'il ya le même auto contrôle voilà les
policiers n'ont pas droit à l'erreur il
ya des professions qui peuvent faire des
erreurs
parler des magistrats tout à l'heure
quelquefois sans aucune solution sans
aucun contrôle il y à un contrôle total
sur la police a pris à des faits et ces
enquêtes se déroulent
s il y à des fautes elles seront
sanctionnées et c'est normal mais
rappelez vous parler de violences
policières
je récuse ce chiffre il y à des faits
qui relèvent de deux enquêtes ou de
condamnation c'est une chose
après on ne peut pas dire que de façon
systémique comme cela a été fait est
quelque peu accrédité par le ministre de
l'intérieur qui a lâché ses hommes il y
à une violence policière la police je
rappellerai d'abord subi des violences
au quotidien parce que si elle fait
usage de la force dans certains cas pour
procéder notamment des interpellations
c'est parce qu'à elles mêmes subi des
violences et on plane et dernière c'est
le rapport de l'igpn et il y a eu je
crois 110 fait ou lors d'interpellations
des personnes ont été blessées par les
policiers ou les gendarmes ont été
blessés
ses parents et il y à chaque jour
jour sens il y a trente policiers et
gendarmes blessés en mission et en
services et il y as ans est agressée ce
sont les chiffres de 2010 800 cette
agression en moyenne par jour contre un
policier un gendarme donc il y a le
problème c'est la montée de la violence
dans notre société pour faire face à
cette violence
ce sont les policiers qui sont le seul
rempart le dernier rempart pour qu'on
puisse toujours continuer à vivre
ensemble parce qu'autrement c'est quoi
c'est la loi des tchétchènes
c'est la loi d'autres communautés
religieuses
c'est la loi de la violence du plus fort
de ce qui vous savez on a vu ces images
dans le mac do là je crois de où les
policiers ont été mis en examen mais
reprend situant ce contexte était le 1er
décembre
les policiers ont défendu la république
l'arc de triomphe ce jour-là a été pillé
c'était une violence totale déjà appelé
à aller à l'elysée
la réalité elle est là ils ont défendu
la république ils ont défendu nos
institutions elle se trouverait on peut
comprendre que harcelé pendant 11 heures
la compagnie de crs qui a été mise en
cause fin les hommes de cette compagnie
il avait travaillé 11 heures pour
poitiers pour sauver la république et au
revoir voilà bon il ya des ya des images
que j'ai vues qui peuvent être
choquantes un effet mais remettons tout
ça dans le contexte ne prenons pas une
image déconnecter totalement la réalité
sociale et entraîner avec une question
sur le terrorisme de numéro dix enfants
de djihadistes ont été rapatriés en
france cette semaine au nom de l'accueil
humanitaire est ce que la france pouvait
faire autrement et doit faire autrement
je soutiens le rapatriement de ses
enfants bien sûr il ya cette question
humanitaire
ces enfants ils sont pour rien dans la
dérive dans le délire de leurs parents
voilà ce sens ce sont des quelques fois
ils sont nés sur les théâtres de guerre
terroriste
donc oui on a en a ce devoir de
protection des enfants après il faut
être naturellement vigilants dans la
façon dont ils vont se reconstruire en
france mais bien entendu moi je soutiens
comme je suis de tout autant que je suis
viscéralement opposé au retour de leurs
parents ou de ceux qui sont allés
combattre sur les zones de guerre et qui
eux ont fait un acte de rupture totale
définitif
c'est un ale qui nous peut être 100 avec
s'accompagner d'un retour en déniant
tout nos valeurs tout ce que nous
croyons en allant vers cette abomination
islamistes eric ce titre toujours sur le
terrorisme le port du bracelet
électronique pendant 10 ans pour des
terroristes ayant déjà purgé leur peine
ça a été voté lors d'une proposition de
loi à l'assemblée nationale porté par
des députés la république en marche
c'est une bonne mesure
je les ai soutenus et d'ailleurs sur ce
bracelet électronique c'est ça c'est pas
un peu une double peine s'est senti ses
mots dans une double peine je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi j'ai soutenu cette
mesure qui avait été retirée par la
majorité remarche en tout cas par la
présidente de la commission des par la
présidente de la commission des lois
et c'est parce que justement on a fait
pression ce bracelet est revenu avec
quelques députés en marche comme
jean-michel fauvergue qui se soit un peu
rebellé parce que ils n'ont pas accepté
qu'on enlève cette mesure je souligne
d'ailleurs que la garde des sceaux était
hostile au bracelet électronique donc
c'est parce qu'il ya eu des députés de
bon sens et et du léger porté cette voie
lundi soir dans l'hémicycle jusqu'à une
heure du matin
koné arrivés à ce résultat et du coup
j'ai voté ce texte mais qu'est-ce de
quoi s'agit-il
on a aujourd'hui 500 terroristes
islamistes condamnés qui est à peu près
un millier de radicaliser la garder soit
10 mois mais les syndicats d'agents
pénitentiaires disent presque 2000 qui
vont sortir de prison dans les années
dans les mois à venir 150 dans l'est
dans les prochaines
les deux prochaines années ils sont
extrêmement dangereux on nous l'a dit le
procureur national anti terroriste a dit
son sac terreur c'est ses mots sa peur
devant cette situation et il nous a dit
que quasiment tous étaient pas
récupérable donc ils présentent un
danger majeur sentiments sont ils ont
purgé une peine là il s'agit de protéger
la société contre des bombes humaines et
il faut qu'il soit sous contrôle et moi
je souhaite qu'on aille beaucoup plus
loin qu'ils soient placés définitivement
rétention de sûreté
le gouvernement n'a pas suivi mais ils
placés en rétention après leur peine
bien sûr parce qu'il représente un
danger c'est ce qu'avait fait nicolas
sarkozy validée par le conseil
constitutionnel pour les criminels
sexuels pour les pédophiles
le danger il est il est d'une même
nature parce que cette rétention et en
même temps qu'ils sont d'argent très
longtemps qu'ils sont dangereux parce
que ce qui compte c'est la protection de
la société d'abord et pour moi c'est ce
qui prime
eric ciotti on va finir par la campagne
municipale avec une question de dennis k
o
alors pour les municipales on a vu que
la république en marche était dans une
situation très compliquée c'est une
élection difficile pour le parti
présidentiel qui du coup a noué des
alliances avec les républicains ces
alliances et ce qu'elles ne risquent pas
de continuer à brouiller l'image du
parti du parti de droite
d'abord quelques chiffres il ya deux
cent soixante douze villes de plus
trente mille habitants dans notre pays
les républicains ont investi 220
candidats il y as au second tour au
second tour si rapprochement locaux
voilà donc la réalité des chiffres on
veut pas dire dans des villes sont pas
moindres il nous avons toujours avec
christian jacob
veillez à ce qui est d'un temps chez it
est forte
voilà après il y à des sujets locaux et
que là notamment pour faire obstacle à
l'extrême gauche qui peut prendre
certaines villes ou les amis de monsieur
michel c aux écolos et les amis de
monsieur mélenchon sont en mesure demain
d'installer leur idéologie dangereuse
donc ce mois je vous connaissez
j'ai toujours était viscéralement
hostile à toute forme d'alliance
je suis pour la clarté voilà et c'est
cette ligne qu'avait christian jacob
nous défendons nous défendrons et que
nous allons bien sûr défendre pour les
élections nationales mais voilà au
premier tour ça a été un très beau
succès pour les républicains
56% des villes depuis de 9000 habitants
ont été gagnés par les républicains à
l'heure où leurs alliés que nous avons
soutenu le résultat il est là c'est une
bérézina total pour en marche qui
n'existe plus qui est en mesure de
gagner
aucune grande ville aujourd'hui dans
dans notre pays qui quelque part a voulu
se rallier à des mères qui avait réussi
je pense que maire de bordeaux je pense
le maire de toulouse bon dont acte mais
ça veut pas dire qu'il ya un
rapprochement structurel
merci beaucoup merci c'est la fin de cet
entretien merci d'avoir été notre invité
merci beaucoup
denis carot demain l'invité politique de
bonjour chez vous ce sera pire person le
député la république en marche de paris